翻訳: Koichiro YODA
校正: Kayoko Shiomi
今日履いてきたこのデニムは
尾道デニムです
2013年1月
日本人のものづくりに込める精神性と
尾道の街の魅力を日本全国にシェアし
そして 世界に発信しようという目的で
尾道デニムプロジェクトは始まりました
ここで用いたメディアは
世界でも多くの方々に
愛されている このデニムです
尾道を含む備後地方は
日本有数のデニムの産地であり
世界的なブランドも手掛けるほどの
クオリティを誇っています
しかし 時代の移り変わりの中で
海外へ生産がシフトし
繊維業全体が 衰退の一途を辿っています
また この尾道は観光地として
名前は知られていますが
新しい文化や旅人を受け入れる
人々の懐の深さという
本来の魅力の発信が
課題の１つでもあります
このプロジェクトに必要なものは
まずこのデニムです
備後地方の職人技が詰まった
ブランド「リゾルト」です
デニムデザイナーの林芳亨氏は
長年 理想のデニムを追い続けてきた方であり
頑ななこだわりで職人たちを
牽引してきた人物でもあります
そして このデニムは
履き込むことで体に馴染んでいく
作りが大きな特徴です
このデニムを 尾道で働く方々に
１人に２本お渡しし
新品の状態でお渡しします
それをワークパンツとして
１年間履いてもらいます
職業は 大工 住職 漁師
農家 保育士など様々
世代は 大学生から70代までと
３世代にわたります
仕事や日々の暮らしの中で
刻まれるシワや
自然な色落ちをすべて個性とし
このデニムの価値とします
機械加工では決して
作り出すことのできない
世界に１本だけの
ビンテージデニムを作り
それを尾道デニムとして発信
販売をしようという試みです
このデニム 履き込むことで
個体差が出ることが大きな特性であり
その特性を生かすため
実際にプロジェクトの
参加者集めがスタートしました
条件は３つ
尾道を愛する人
個性的な人
そして 最低でも週４日
デニムを履いて働けることです
目標人数は200名
当初 右も左もわからない
街で取り組むプロジェクト
もちろん知り合いもいません
そんな中
街の取り組みの中心人物を
紹介していただく機会に恵まれ
直接このプロジェクトの趣旨を
プレゼンすることとなります
中には「自分たちが履いた
デニムに価値があるのか？」
「デニムを履くことがどのように
町おこしに繋がるのか？」などと
いろんな疑問を投げかけられる
こともありましたが
結果として「 面白いからとりあえず
やってみよう」という声から始まり
270名の方たちと
スタートすることができました
このように
前例のないことでも 面白がって取り組む
尾道の方たちがいるからこそ
そして 人のつながりを大切にする
尾道の人たちだからこそ
このプロジェクトは 今でも
熱を持って継続できています
しかし これらの価値を伝えていくためにも
ただ履きこんだデニムを
作ればいいというわけではありません
ビンテージデニムとしての
クオリティ管理も大切にしました
特にこの映像にある洗い方について
参加者の方々にお渡したデニムは
基本的に 好きに履き込んで
もらっていいのですが
家庭での洗濯は極力避け
デザイナーが信頼する 島根県の
洗いの専門工場にお送りします
そのために 毎週木曜日の
配布回収は欠かせません
参加者の仕事現場に
直接回収しに行ったり
履いているデニムを 私たちの方に
持ってきて頂いたりと
コミュニケーションを取りながら
毎週毎週 配布回収を行いました
そして 回収したデニムは
島根県の工場に送り
職人さんたちが目を通して
丁寧に洗いにかけます
この「履く」「洗う」という工程を
毎週 経年変化を確認しながら
１年間繰り返します
この一見手間がかかる
作業を欠かさないことが
それこそが 日本人の
ものづくりの精神性であり
このデニムに刻まれた個性が
より磨かれる秘密です
こうして出来上がったデニムには
参加者の職業やライフスタイルの
違いが刻まれています
例えば こちらのデニム
これは 尾道で働く
漁師さんが履いたものです
よく見ると ここに白い線が入ってます
これは 長靴を履いて
働く時に出来た皺です
奥のデニム
少しこの辺が黒くなっています
あと ここの辺りに
少し白い穴が開いています
この職業は
鉄工所で働く職人さんです
溶接の時に飛び散る火花や鉄粉が
このデニムに刻まれています
このようにたくさんの
個性が刻まれたデニムは
色落ちや状態に合わせた
値段の付け方になっていますが
実は 履き手の個性そのものが
このデニムの大きな価値となっているのです
そして 2014年3月
尾道商店街に 尾道デニムショップが
オープンしました
インターネットなどの販売はせず
基本的には このお店での
対面販売になります
そうすることで 遠方からわざわざ
尾道デニムとの出会いを楽しみに
足を運んで下さる
流れが生まれてきました
ちなみに 第１号の購入者は
地元の高校生
バイトで稼いだお金を握りしめて
デニムを買いに来てくれた姿を
今でも強く思い出すことができます
私がこのプロジェクトを企画した原動力
それは タイやインドでの経験を
通じて感じた 心が震えるようなもの ー
心から感動することを
大切な方に伝えたいという思いからです
20代の頃 物が無いなら無いなりの
生活を経験してみようと
タイ北部に位置するチェンライに行き
そこで１年間生活をしました
そのシンプルな暮らしから
生きていくために働くという
大切なことを学びました
そして この画像はインドの地
ジャイサルメールと言います
ジャイサルメールは
黄金の町と呼ばれています
この街に夕日が落ちる瞬間
街一帯が黄金色に輝く風景を目にし
とてつもなく感動をし
この感動を大切な人たちに伝えたいと
ホテルの立ち上げに携わることになります
帰国後は ここでのこれらの経験を
どうにか別の形で生かせないか
そう考えたのです
そんな中 東日本大震災があり
被害のあった福島県南相馬市の現状を知り
何かできないかと考えました
大切なのは 記憶を風化させないこと
日常が当たり前ではないということ
そして みんなが繋がっているということ
それらの気づきを促すような
写真店を運営しました
その手法は 震災から半年
そして１年の日の空の写真を
SNSや口コミで 世界中
日本中から数千枚集め
それらを１枚の写真に繋ぎ
想いと共に被災地へ
寄贈するというものです
もちろん 我々の想いと共に
皆さんの集めた想いと共に寄贈しました
この参加型の作品作りという手法から
この尾道デニムプロジェクトは
ヒントを得ています
そして 自然な流れでいただいた
この尾道の仕事
瀬戸内の観光を資源に
地域に事業と雇用を創出するという
会社の理念に共感をし
また 訪れた尾道の街や
人に大変感動をし
この街で働くことを決意しました
この尾道の街は
昔も今も これからも
変わらない普遍的な価値が脈々と
受け継がれている街です
この街を舞台に
今 何が本当に大切かの本質を探り
価値あることを 日本全国
そして 世界へとシェアしていけるのです
働くこと 生きることの
価値を問い直したい
そして 今を生きる自分たちが
本当に必要なものが何かを
大切かを考え続けたい
それを試行錯誤しながら
表現しようとしているのが
このデニムプロジェクトなのです
そんな１年目の運営の中で
見えてきた課題を改善するために
プロジェクトはフェイズ２へ移行します
フェーズ１ではプロジェクトの
立ち上げとショップのオープン
そしてフェイズ２では 尾道デニムを
尾道から日本全国 そして世界へと
広めていこうという試みに挑戦しました
このプロジェクトの広がりに
クリエイティブの存在は欠かせません
デザインやSNSを活用する一方で
あくまでも 人から人へとこのデニムの
価値を伝えていきたいと考えました
その手法の一つに
この「尾道デニムスターターキット」
新品のデニムとこのキットを
購入していただくと
デニムの内側にロットナンバーの
スタンプが押され
尾道デニムの最大の特徴である
履いた後の洗いー
風合いを出す洗いを専門の
工場で体験することができます
自分のデニムを一から育てるという
楽しみを体験できるキットです
そして ２つ目に「尾道デニムキャラバン」
尾道になかなか足を運べない方のために
尾道デニムを尾道以外の土地に持ち込み
対面で魅力をお伝えする
そんな試みです
訪れた土地で 新たな人との繋がりを作り
またそこで発見した魅力を
尾道デニムというメディアを
通して発信することで
メディアとしてのあり方を深めています
ここで大切なのは
売り上げだけではなく
きちんと皆様に価値を
お伝えすることです
尾道デニムが伝えていきたいことを
まだまだいろんな人たちに伝えるために
テレビや雑誌 新聞などの
メディアの拡散に頼るだけではなく
あくまでも人から人へと
繋げていきたいと そう考えています
そんな中で生まれた企画が
この「旅するデニム」
国内外問わず 尾道デニムの意思を
受け継いでくれる方に
尾道デニムを実際にお渡しし
履き育ててもらいます
新たな履き手とともに履き込むことで
そのデニムには 新しい物語が刻まれます
同時に 履き手の皆様には
その土地の暮らし 文化 働き方など
デニムに刻まれるストーリーを
シェアしてもらいます
現在では 京都の職人さん
萩のゲストハウスオーナー
自転車で世界一周中の旅人
そして ドイツに留学中の青年など
様々な方に履き育ててもらいます
これらのデニムも いつか旅先から
尾道に戻ってきて
また販売され 別の方の手に渡る予定です
［デニムでつなぐ物語］
尾道デニムを履く全ての方々が
物語の主人公です
何百人の手に尾道デニムが渡り
いつか尾道に戻ってくること
その時のデニムの深みを増した表情
履き手の物語を聴ける日が
来ることを楽しみにしています
そして このプロジェクトは決して
一人では成立しないプロジェクトです
頑ななこだわりで理想のデニムを
追い続けてきたデザイナーと
備後の繊維業界に
危機を感じていた者との出会い
そして ファッション業界に
携わり続ける者だからこそ知る
価値あるものづくりの大変さ
尾道デニムの価値を表現してくれた
グラフィックデザイナー
テレビで尾道デニムのことを知り
関東から飛んできた女の子は
今ではショップの看板娘です
そして何より
前例のないことでも
面白がって受け入れてくれた尾道の方々は
味のあるデニムを育てる職人なのです
このように 尾道デニムを通して
街と人との出会いが繋がり
働くことに誇りを持つきっかけとなり
誰かの人生と尾道の街とに
新たな出会いが生まれました
こうしてこのプロジェクトは
シンプルな答えにたどり着くのです
一生懸命働くことは カッコいいということ
その街の風土は 人々の日々の営みの
積み重ねが作り出す歴史であるということ
そして 人にはそれぞれ個性や物語があり
そこに価値を見出すのは
自分自身であるということです
私たちは この世界を生きる
一人ひとりの人生が
時代を作る上で
とても大切な一端を担っているということ
繋がっていること
そして 輝いているということを
このプロジェクトを通して 表現し
伝えていくことができる
そう信じています
（拍手）